Laak going on in Washington this
offseason you know they had a great year
in 2018 until Alec Smith suffered that
gruesomely broken leg and the
organization went into a tailspin after
that they're trying to get it right now
they got so much money tied up in Alec
Smith that they have to be smart in what
they spend on quarterbacks they have
Colt McCoy case Makena picked up Dwayne
Haskins with the 15th selection in the
draft who knows who's gonna start week
one I think what coy is going to be gone
and it's gonna be down to Keenum and
Haskins I actually think keenum could
maybe be good enough to hold off Haskins
for a while but you know Shireen it's a
quarterback driven league and when
you're the Cowboys and you're looking at
with the Giants who knows what they're
gonna do and Washington who knows what
they're gonna do it feels like it's a
two team division because I feel like
it's gonna take a while for Washington
to figure out exactly where they are and
what kind of team they're gonna be with
these different quarterbacks to choose
from yeah you know it's another team
that I really like what they've done at
the quarterback position considering
where they were their options after Alex
Smith's injury last season in Colt
McCoy's injury last season I like the
two moves they've made a quarterback to
hopefully for them for their sake to
kind of bridge them getting to Haskins
full-time this is a pretty decent
football team attic coach from another
team outside the division tell me he
likes washington's front seven better
than any other front seven in football
they have an offensive line obviously
things stay healthy they didn't last
season but if they can stay healthy it's
one of the best offensive lines in
football so I this is a really good
football team outside of the question
mark at quarterback is Case Keenum gonna
start week one I think we all figure he
will and if he does how is he gonna play
you know he's only really been a
full-time starter the last two seasons
and he's through 40 touchdowns to 21
interceptions but there's also a reason
that he's on his third team in three
years and you know one of the things
that will help whoever the quarterback
is the running game in Adrian Peterson
one of the pleasant surprises last year
for Washington he was on the couch
August 19 ends up joining the team and
leading the the franchise in rushing
they have Darius guys who's expected to
be back for training camp it took a
flyer on Bryce law
and his ACL tear from Stanford and you
know they may have too many quality
running backs it may be another
situation where Adrian Peterson is like
hey when am I gonna get the football
especially if guys lives up to his
potential but they could get it done in
the running game which would set up the
passing game and you mentioned that
offensive line that was one of the big
attractions for Adrian Peterson and they
did not disappoint it was a solid
offensive line last year if they can
stay healthy and if they can get the
running game going it does become easier
for Keenum it becomes easier for Haskins
whoever the quarterback is but you know
I I just think I think keenum has just
been passed around from team to team for
his entire career he was spectacular in
2017 in Minnesota and it's just a matter
of trying to you know go back and find
the plays that worked in Minnesota used
those plays if key if Case Keenum is the
guy and I think Washington can end up
being far better than we we expect them
to be I mean there's always gonna be bad
teams in the NFL and chances are the
teams that are traditionally bad will be
bad but there is reason for hope on both
sides of the ball in Washington yeah
this is not gonna be a bad football team
this is gonna be a football team a Nate
Nate football team that if they get a
break or two maybe they win nine or ten
and if they don't get those breaks maybe
they win seven games but you know this
is one of those teams that can go either
way but I do think on paper they're a
decent football team it's all gonna
depend on how Case Keenum plays now I do
think he had more talent at the receiver
position and at the tight end position
in Minnesota than he has in Washington
that's one thing I worry about for him
is what kind of talent he has to throw
to
but that running game is way better than
what he had in Minnesota and as you said
with all those running backs the only
thing that Washington has to worry about
is guys complaining about not getting
the football they they should be able to
run the football and they should be able
to run the football really really well
behind that offensive line and with
those running backs and the name to
watch defensively rookie Montes sweat
they traded back into round one with the
Colts to get him he ran a four for one
in the 40 at the Scouting Combine there
was some sort of a heart problem was
detected there there's discrepancy over
whether or not it's a big deal multiple
teams had him off the draft board
Washington clearly didn't if this guy
comes in and makes an impact right away
especially with Rueben foster now out
for the year so that does take a little
piece out of the the front
seven the ruben foster suffers the ACL
tear and OTAs on monday but if sweat can
come in make an impact Jay Gruden's
already said expect to see him play a
lot this year that that's you know we
get caught up in analyzing offenses and
defenses but the thing that helps an
offense more than anything else is a
great defense and the thing that helps a
defense it more than anything else is a
great offense and the the Washington
franchise may have some balance here and
if you have balance that's how you end
up being successful in the only stat
that matters Sherine more points scored
than the opponent on a per game basis
yeah absolutely and so many people love
Montes sweat I think that the medical
question was the only question that some
people had but I think he's going to be
a really good football player and I
think he went to a team that he can be a
really good football player immediately
and come in and do certain things and
that's to rush the passer and get after
the passer this is again a really really
good front seven and they're gonna get
after the quarterback and you better
have a good offensive line which we know
Dallas and Philadelphia do and that's
the two teams that a division that
they're chasing but you better have a
good offensive line you better get rid
of the ball quickly against this
defensive line Vegas has the over-under
for wins this year for Washington it's
six and a half based on what you were
saying a couple of minutes ago it sounds
like we can put you down for the over
I'm the over put me over yeah and and I
agree with that too especially because
they're gonna have a couple of games
against the Giants I don't think the
John's gonna be very good this year and
and I just think Washington thing get
back to that vibe they were in early
last season when they were just
methodically winning games maybe
surprising people there's always those
teams that we we really don't know what
to think of them and the next thing you
know they're 3 and 1 and you know if
they can sustain it then they become one
of those teams that we we had no idea
they were gonna make it to the playoffs
and eventually they're they are playing
in January and that's one of the fun
things of every NFL season there's
always going to be teams like that that
we didn't see coming and maybe we should
see Washington coming here's what's
coming next as we continue on this
Wednesday edition of PFT live a draft of
the most unsatisfying finishes in NFL
history we'll be back with more after
this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports